the world of work the world of learning
the world of play all altered perhaps
forever by a virus that's changed
everything
there is only one teacher that teacher
in the real world can only teach 30
people
that teacher in a virtual world could
teach an infinite number of people
past months that have forced us to be a
part have also brought lessons about how
better to share resources
while apart so we've been living in a
pandemic where we've seen vr
double triple in in sales and that's
been driven by
forced remote behavior but in the
in the world we're moving to i think
it's going to be a choice that you make
it's going to be hybrid sometimes remote
sometimes in person and the amount of
experiences that you can have through
virtual reality connecting with people
learning from people is going to mean
that there are going to be a lot of
places
and a lot of instances or just safer
better
cheaper to use virtual reality than to
go back to the old behaviors
this is what it takes to put on an
international technology show
in the age of covid there's large-scale
testing digital proof of covered status
and a mobile world congress diminished
by travel restrictions yet for all that
it is able to tell us something about
communications and technology after the
pandemic
when all of this is gone holograms will
be the future
it will be the only way that we look at
our computer screens phones or any phone
calls
if you thought zoom was cool try
chatting to a hologram
zoom has been a fantastic connection for
people but it's definitely lacked
the ability to emotionally engage the
same level that we had before
so this is really a stepping stone that
we see to allow people to get back to
that
emotional engagement doesn't matter if
you're in japan and i'm in the united
states or we're across the entire planet
you can still engage with somebody at
the same level that you used or at least
in a better way than we have had
the return of big events like this one
show that in some parts of the world the
pandemic is loosening its grip
it also suggests that we won't be
returning to things
quite as we left them this is futurist
cecilia tam people have changed in terms
of their behavior
companies have understood that their
boundaries
are more malleable technologies are
increasing
capacity and so all of the indications
are telling me that
we will be within this range to what ex
extent you know how far are we gonna let
people work at home and versus how how
far are we gonna
move everyone back uh that is to see but
we're not gonna
we're not gonna go back like before the
technology of the future
feels like it owes much to social
distancing anticipating perhaps that
social distancing
will not entirely become a thing of the
past
joe nahul al jazeera barcelona